on va passer au débat de ce club on va
parler de l'économie de la montagne de
son avenir la montagne qui n'échappa à
la contestation contre la réforme des
retraites Audrey pétaz vous vous êtes
rendu cette semaine au Deux Alpes oui
les saisonniers qui enchaînent les
contrats courts monte au créneau parce
que leur pénibilité n'est pas prise en
compte et ne le sera vraisemblablement
pas dans la réforme des retraites qui
arrivent débray ils organisent des
débrayages qui pourraient avoir des
conséquences alors que les vacances
scolaires commencent à la fin de la
semaine regardez
il est 8h30 la station des Deux Alpes se
révé d'ordinaire ces pisteurs
secouristes et employés des remontées
sont déjà en poste dans les sommets ce
jour-là ils auront une heure de retard
un rapide débrayage pour marquer le coup
et interpeller les skieurs il faut
vraiment qu'on explique nos carrières
sur morcelées que la pénibilité n'est
pas toujours prise en compte et que du
coup ça nous fait partir à la retraite
dans des mauvaises conditions et on
voulait vraiment que vous l'entendiez et
pour s'en rendre compte il faut monter à
3200 mètres d'altitude au bout de cette
échelle ce pisteur intervient sur un
câble de remontée un peu plus loin un
agent distribue les perches le vent
souffle il fait moins 10 degrés et c'est
ce qu'on appelle une très belle journée
c'est pas tout le temps comme ça des
fois ça neige à l'horizontale il y a du
vent de partout il y a du givre collé
sur tous les pylônes sur toutes les
longueurs de corne on a 12 km de
longueur de corde et faut tout taper à
la massette et il faut faire des
interventions électriques des
interventions de maintenance et c'est
très compliqué les grosses journées ici
il y a 10 000 personnes qui embarquent
donc pendant toute la journée dans le
froid parfois dans le vent à faire des
tâches répétitives et tout ça tu as zéro
de pénibilité tu prends ton compte
pénibilité tu regardes dessus tu es à 0
il y a deux raisons à cela le froid
n'est pas un facteur de pénibilité et
c'est saisonniers enchaînent les
contrats courts on cumule tous de 1 à 4
boulots dans l'année parce que le but
c'est de boucler les 12 mois et la
pénibilité ne se cumule pas en théorie
avec la réforme des retraites ils
devront partir à 64 ans insoutenable
d'après au-delà d'un certain âge c'est
des métiers qu'on peut plus traverser et
on retrouvera pas un boulot ailleurs à
50 ans passés c'est très compliqué on en
connaît dans qui ont fait le même métier
que nous ils sont tellement abîmés qui
profitent pas de la retraite war même
leur vie est écourtée
à 64 ans mais dans 5 ans ça se fera 66
68 je vais casser de la glace je vais
planter des pieux dégivrer des cordes à
70 ans sur à 3000 mètres d'altitude pour
finir quoi entre quatre planches et
merci au revoir mais faut arrêter là des
revendications plutôt bien comprises par
les skieurs
bon si c'est pas toute la semaine ça va
mais il faut marquer je comprends tout à
fait par la direction aussi qui a besoin
de ces saisonniers c'est clair que sans
nos saisonniers on fonctionne pas on a
600 saisonniers nos parents donc sans
fonctionner on ferme nos domaines il y a
pas de problème ce que j'espère c'est
que pendant les vacances il n'y aura pas
de mouvement en fait ce que ce que l'on
va travailler avec nos délégués
syndicaux c'est peut-être qu'ils aient
le droit de l'expression tout en étant à
leur poste de travail car une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation est prévue en
station le 7 en pleine période des
vacances scolaires
celle qu'elle va vous entendez les
inquiétudes et la colère de ces
saisonniers qui enchaîne contre à court
sans prise en compte de la pénibilité et
qui disent on ne se voit pas faire ça 64
ans ah oui j'attends clairement leur
préoccupation une après ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y a un mouvement qui a été fait et je
remercie quand même qui n'a pas porté
conséquence non plus sur les stations en
tout cas minima donc il y a quand même
eu une responsabilité qui a été prise on
peut remercier syndicat et aussi les
pistes secouristes après il faut
regarder qu'il y a également des
revendications qui touchent à
l'assurance chômage donc parce que je
pense que les deux étaient cumulés et
quand on entend clairement aujourd'hui
les personnes dire à 64 ans avec le
froid etc je pense que bien évidemment
c'est des thématiques sur lesquelles on
doit prendre en considération même si
globalement je pense que d'après
certaines informations le fait d'avoir
1200 euros peut permettre d'avoir
aujourd'hui une retraite qui soit plus
importante qu'avant ceci étant il faudra
bien qu'on regarde les effets de bord
pour être sûr de pas avoir ses effets
hachés et que la totalité soit bien
prise en compte
les 1200 euros déjà il faut avoir une
retraite pleine pour beaucoup de
saisonniers ça sera pas le cas parce
qu'ils ont des carrières hachées on sait
pertinemment que pour certains ça va
être la double peine et le chômage parce
que certaines iront plus droit et même à
la fin de cette saison d'hiver ça c'est
quand même je pense particulièrement
pénalisant pour ceux qui se sont
sédentarisés parce que quelque part leur
vie tourner malheureusement
autour du chômage mais encore
faudrait-il que on puisse leur proposer
autre chose à l'intersaison et je pense
qu'on avait fait des propositions au
niveau du gouvernement pour justement
pour faire une étude de faisabilité de
l'emploi à l'intersaison il a échoué
parce qu'on s'est pertinemment qu'on
arrivera jamais à caser tous les
saisonniers ensuite pour les histoires
de retraite ben oui effectivement pour
les permanents des remontées mécaniques
pour ceux qui ont eu au départ de leur
vie et une saisonnalité ils vont arriver
en fin de carrière à 67 68 ans est-ce là
encore on n'a pas tous mais je vous
garantis que le métier les métiers des
permanents de remontées mécaniques c'est
encore beaucoup plus difficile que ce
qu'on a pu voir là donc le tout cumulé
bien évidemment les salariés s'y
retrouve plus et bien évidemment si on
met pas des mesures en face et c'est pas
les points de pénibilité c'est des
métiers qui doivent être reconnus
pénibles parce que bon c'est bien joli
pour vous la bataille majeure
aujourd'hui au delà des 64 ans c'est que
la pénibilité soit reconnue que la
pénibilité des métiers en général soit
reconnu et ensuite il est bien évident
qu'on peut pas continuer de faire
travailler des gens jusqu'à 64 ans c'est
une hérésie complète pour beaucoup on
sait pertinemment qui commence à
travailler relativement tard ça va
décaler alors on est en train d'essayer
une nous vendre une une réforme des
retraites alors qu'on pourrait très bien
et on va pas entamer le débat là-dessus
faire autrement les salariés seraient
complètement prêt et on a fait des
sondages à payer un petit peu plus le
côté alors que
et je pense que la retraite serait
largement sinon égalitaire
au moins bénéficiaire en fait ce que
m'expliquait les saisonniers aussi c'est
que l'hiver ils sont dans les stations
et l'été beaucoup travaillent souvent
dans le BTP donc on est aussi sur des
emplois où il y a de la pénibilité et en
fait la pénibilité ne se cumule pas donc
si vous faites un contrat court de deux
mois vous allez faire par exemple de la
dameuse de nuit vous allez travailler
pendant 60 nuits il en faut 120 à
l'année pour que la pénibilité soit
prise en compte et donc à la fin on se
retrouve à la fin de l'année avec des
emplois qui sont pénibles moi je l'ai vu
c'était une belle journée il faisait il
faisait moins 10 il y avait un petit peu
de ventre 30 degrés mais on m'a dit que
des fois c'était moins 25 avec du vent
des charges lourdes des pylônes à monter
et à la fin 0 on le compte pénibilité
parce que ça ne se cumule pas vous allez
travailler là-dessus au Sénat Cyril
felvin sur est-ce qu'il y aura par
exemple un amendement pour la question
spécifique des saisonniers dans cette
station de ski je pense à partir
où on va avoir de plus en plus de gens
qui seront sans logement et sans aucun
sans aucun revenu quasiment et ça c'est
inadmissible pour des salariés qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie qui soit
permanent ou qui soit saisonniers mais
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
quand même on marche sur la tête quoi
Benjamin marriage je vais vous faire
réagir vous êtes avec nous puis Annecy
je le rappelle première adjoint au maire
d'Annecy quel est votre réaction vous
entendez vous évidemment les inquiétudes
de ces saisonniers
bien sûr merci et bonjour bonjour à
toutes et à tous pour
de notre côté le point de vue d'Annecy
il est un petit peu différent parce que
effectivement on voit pas la saison
plutôt hivernale on voit la saison
estivale où on a aussi ces enjeux de
saisonnalité très fort sur sur la le
bassin de vie anestien moi ce que
j'entends ici c'est la question
systémique au sens où c'est le système
de notre modèle de développement des
territoires de montagne qui est qui est
mis à mal par notamment ce monsieur que
Monsieur becquier évoqué sur la question
du changement climatique qui vient
raccourcir les saisons de manière
très rapide à l'échelle d'une génération
c'est c'est jamais vu et donc clairement
cela vient chercher la question de
l'employabilité de la formation de des
saisonniers pour pouvoir aussi rebondir
à l'intersaison et je pense que c'est là
où en tant que bassin de vie et bassin
de de travail qui est que nous qui vont
sur Annecy et ça va plus généralement en
avant une chance d'avoir aussi une un
tissu économique très riche qui a aussi
besoin de main d'oeuvre toute l'année
sur différentes métiers et notamment les
métiers de la transition écologique qui
deviennent aussi un enjeu de pouvoir
trouver cette manœuvre donc là je pense
qu'ici il y a quelque chose
cette transformation de l'économie de la
montagne mais pour finir sur ce
mouvement de grève
Eric BK est-ce qu'il est suivi déjà et
est-ce qu'il va durer Audrey le disait
dans son reportage il y a une prochaine
journée mardi est-ce que vous envoyez
d'autres alors que commencent les
vacances de février qui sont vitales
pour cessation de ski oui effectivement
il est très suivi on a vu le 19 une
mobilisation jamais atteinte sur le plan
particulièrement des remontées
mécaniques en général le 31 un petit peu
plus et là pour le 7 nous organisons non
pas des mobilisations dans des grands
centres on va essayer de faire passer le
message auprès de la clientèle par lui
de débrayage alors d'une heure deux
heures une matinée chacun choisira afin
son mode d'action parce qu'il faut qu'on
impérativement on arrive à avoir une
relation directe avec la clientèle on
n'est pas là pour il faut qu'il
comprenne que c'est nous qui sommes
pénalisés et que de fait eux le sont
mais c'est le système qui quelque part
nous oblige c'est nous qui sont pris en
otage
il y aura des amendements qui seront
déposés par une députée PS au moment de
l'examen de l'Assemblée mais les
saisonniers ont peur qu'on n'est pas le
temps d'examiner ces amendements parce
que des amendements on le sait il y en a
beaucoup et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
essayent de se faire entendre en faisant
des débrayages alors pour l'instant ça
reste très
c'est soft en effet c'est en accord
aussi avec la direction et ils ont
débrayé une heure avant l'ouverture des
stations c'était soft ça pourrait
éventuellement monter en puissance si
jamais ils sont pas entendus
ça montre en puissance vous entendez que
il faut marquer l'opinion et est-ce que
ça vous inquiète vous serrez le pelva
pour l'économie de ces stations de ski
l'économie de ces communes à un moment
vital dans la saison alors je pense
qu'il y a un point qui est important
c'est que aujourd'hui j'entends qu'il
faut se faire entendre et qu'il y a des
messages à faire passer et honnêtement
moi je suis à 100% d'accord sur les
messages à faire passer maintenant je
pense qu'il faut aussi rassurer la
clientèle parce que quand on voit
certains médias la presse on commence à
effrayer les gens qui se disent est-ce
que je vais venir en station ou pas
est-ce que ça va être fermé toute la
semaine ou pas quelque part d'avoir des
mouvements débrayage 5 minutes comme
j'ai entendu
une heure avant l'ouverture etc et qu'on
fasse passer par le voir par la voix des
de tractages etc à la mobilisation je
pense que c'est une quelque chose qui
est louable et qui voilà mais par contre
il faut bien rassurer les gens comme
quoi sur les vacances il y aura de
l'activité avec peut-être des
perturbations liées aux revendications
qui sont légitimes mais il faut qu'on
aille un message aussi positif sinon
effectivement je serai inquiet pour
notre économie de montagne qui a déjà
souffert entre Noël et Nouvel An par le
manque de neige et qui a souffert ces
deux dernières années avec la crise de
la covid mais je pense que si on doit
apporter un message positif il faut
qu'on en reçoivent
de positif également parce que je vous
dis on en serait pas là si on avait été
écouté
et on l'a jamais été moi j'ai rencontré
Madame Pénicaud j'ai rencontré Madame
bon ça n'a jamais bouger on a on a
proposé de mettre en place une réfection
sur l'assaisonnalité en disant on va
mettre pour l'emploi dans la boucle on
va essayer de proposer des formations en
fonction des compétences des besoins du
bassin d'emploi parce qu'il faut pas
qu'on envoie les gens à 500 km de là une
femme qui élève ses enfants toute seule
elle va faire comment pour se déplacer
donc pour beaucoup ils se sont
sédentarisés parce qu'ils avaient on a
fait des propositions concrètes on a
reçu aucun retour alors bien évidemment
là on en est là et c'est sûr que il faut
affoler un peu la population et c'est le
but
Benjamin Marie est-ce que vous vous
comprenez ce que dit
Eric becquet est-ce que vous vous êtes
inquiet pour l'économie de la commune
d'Annecy dans cette période
je vais être sur Annecy non c'est pas
c'est pas un enjeu nous avons une petite
station qui s'appelle le Semnoz qui est
juste au-dessus d'Annecy après les
autres stations sur La Clusaz
Grand-Bornand au plus proche
est-ce que aussi les grandes stations
qui sont à proximité d'Annecy ça fait
pas aussi du monde du côté d'Annecy
bien sûr bien sûr si si c'est pour pour
l'ensemble de la filière de la
restauration notamment c'est un enjeu
c'est l'enjeu fort mais moi je le
comprends entièrement les revendications
portées par Monsieur becquet aujourd'hui
et c'est je pense que la vraie la vraie
question derrière ça c'est
que ce dialogue-là n'a jamais eu lieu
encore et ça a été exprimé et les crises
successives les cris successives qui
arrivent maintenant viennent et que ça
exacerber en fait chacune de chacune des
revendications sur la pénibilité sur la
durée de la saison sur la dépendance de
l'industrie du ski pour les territoires
de montagne et ça c'est effectivement et
c'est pas la même chose dans chaque
vallée et c'est là peut-être aussi la
difficulté c'est que nous avons
une grande différence entre savoir la
Haute-Savoie de par notre configuration
géographique de par les acteurs
économiques sur le territoire
on a voilà et je pense qu'il faut le
traiter aussi de manière plus fine sur
sur ces territoires là
pour revenir sur ce que disait Benjamin
marié avant cette intervention plus
largement sur l'économie de la montagne
est-ce qu'il faut revoir tout ça est-ce
qu'il y a une inquiétude sur l'avenir de
la montagne est-ce qu'il y a une baisse
du nombre de skieurs est-ce qu'avec la
transition écologique qui aura moins de
neige donc moins de ski est-ce qu'il
faut que les stations de montagne se
réadaptent et après on verra avec vous
avec Becker sera des conséquences sur
les saisonniers et les employés
concernés écoutez moi des chiffres que
j'ai pu avoir notamment en ce qui
concerne la Haute-Savoie la saison
dernière donc celle qui a succédé à la
covid n'a jamais été aussi importante en
termes de chiffre d'affaires et en
termes de journée de journée ski donc on
voit que la montagne est la neige attire
encore bien évidemment du fait du
dérèglement climatique et du changement
il faut que aujourd'hui les stations
préparent la suite ou du moins puissent
le préparer en étant alors elles aiment
pas le terme des quatre saisons mais en
tout cas sur des deux saisons plus avec
un allongement sur les ailes de la
saison et de proposer des activités
annexes qui vont pouvoir après amener
des personnes en dehors de ces
périodes-là ou le cas échéant contient
manque de neige de pouvoir changer de
modèle ça a été le cas notamment sur la
commune des Gets il y a eu un secteur du
domaine qui n'était pas enneigé entre
Noël et Nouvel An ils ont basculé ils
ont remis les VTT ils ont fait 1000
journées forfaits et donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les stations s'adaptent
de plus même si c'est la neige
aujourd'hui qui attire les gens le
nombre d'heures qui est en baisse et
finalement les personnes qui viennent
c'est pas toute la famille qu'est-ce
qu'ils n'ont plus et après se tournent
déjà vers d'autres activités donc ça
reste la neige qui est le moteur par
contre bien évidemment les journées
d'enneigement et la masse de neige sera
moins dans les années à venir même si
elle sera encore pérenne on a quand même
des outils aujourd'hui comme pinkslow
qui le permettent et après il faut
qu'elles en profitent pour basculer
gentiment pour compléter leurs revenus
et après peut-être qu'on arrivera à
avoir des cdialisations pour pouvoir
après
est-ce que du coup il faut aussi changer
le modèle de l'emploi je vais vous poser
après la question avec des gens qui ne
seraient peut-être plus saisonniers plus
ultra court mais qui exercérait en CDI
des métiers différents selon les quatre
saisons mais c'est sûr moi je en tout
cas pour parler avec un certain nombre
d'employeurs de dire on a 10 mois plein
et après deux mois de récupération sous
un format CDI qui permettra après de
s'installer de pas faire des
déplacements de pouvoir après évoluer au
sein d'une structure etc permettra je
l'espère alors pour ceux qui le veulent
on pourra pas avoir enfin les besoins en
hiver ne sont pas les mêmes besoins
qu'en été mais on pourrait avoir déjà
une masse de saisonnier qui pourrait
déjà s'installer et vivre et vivre
décemment et après on pourra travailler
aussi en parallèle sur les critères de
pénibilité à rajouter etc donc là dessus
on a enfin ça pourrait être une solution
pour vous c'est un peu c'est une forme
de solution qu'on avait proposé c'est
une étude de faisabilité mais le
problème c'est qu'on s'est pertinemment
qu'on n'arrivera jamais à caser tous les
saisonniers qu'on rencontre sur les
massifs on n'arrivera jamais à les caser
à l'intersaison c'est pas vrai pour
répondre quand même la pression
l'exercice effectivement ce qui a
exacerbé la réaction des sal ce sont les
mesures du chômage et de la retraite
c'est pas autre chose maintenant je vais
revenir au sujet et c'est vrai qu'on a
étudié d'autres systèmes de
fonctionnement vous avez les visites qui
commencent à prendre même l'hiver il y a
du quarté électrique vous avez des
sentiers piétons qui peuvent être entre
remis en circuit enfin en fonction vous
avez des circuits raquettes mais ça
remplacera jamais le ski on s'est
piercing avant que la masse de skieur
qu'on a parce qu'il y a de la neige on
pourra jamais le remplacer pour autre
chose et il faut quand même qu'on s'y
fasse cette idée là après bon on a quand
même des moyens de produire de la neige
maintenant qui sont largement plus
performants que ce qu'ils étaient leur
par le passé
qui ne perturbe perturbe pas en réalité
l'écosystème parce que ça il y a eu
plein plein de choses qui ont été dites
qui sont complètement fausse mais en
dehors du ski je pense que il faut qu'on
arrive effectivement à fidéliser et
fidéliser et les salariés parce que si
on trouve plus des salariés compétents
on va effectivement rogner aussi sur la
clientèle parce que on demande des
compétences salariés on leur demande
d'être présent et accompagner
systématiquement le client quel qu'il
soit que ce soit hôtellerie qui a fait
restauration ailleurs si on perd ses
compétences professionnelles et cette
envie de bien faire vous savez dans les
Romains mécaniques je le sais pour y
avoir travaillé 36 ans donc et j'étais
au service de maintenance donc je sais
ce que c'est que l'intervenir quand vous
avez toute une nuit sur un appareil pour
que le matin il tourne il faut vraiment
avoir envie de le faire si on perd cette
envie les appareils tourneront pas le
lendemain matin essayez c'est un tout je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait une réflexion
sur qu'est-ce que sont les métiers de la
montagne qui soit permanent saisonnier
des remontées mécaniques ou d'ailleurs
et que globalement on ait une réflexion
sur cette spécificité saison et ça on
l'a jamais eu et c'est catastrophique
parce qu'on est en train de perdre ce
qu'on a construit au fil des ans
dans le cas des Deux Alpes c'est aussi
pour ça que la direction accompagne un
petit peu le mouvement parce qu'en fait
depuis la crise du covid on manque de
saisonnier comme dans de nombreux
secteurs et le fait qu'il y ait cette
pénibilité qui ne soit pas forcément
cumulable et qui est des conditions qui
soient compliquées ça inquiète aussi les
responsables des stations qui se disent
nous sont les saisonniers on ferme ouais
Benjamin Marie je vais vous faire réagir
à ça
mais oui justement parce que je trouve
passionnant le l'approche de Monsieur
becquet c'est que on a on a eu la chance
d'avoir un plan neige massif dans les
années 70 aujourd'hui on est à l'heure
de la planification
avec une reprise en main on va dire de
la planification et là je trouverais
vraiment passionnant justement que nous
saisissions cette opportunité à
l'échelle nationale pour se dire mais
c'est quoi en fait la montagne demain et
c'est quoi notre plan pour la montagne
demain et pour sortir aussi du du
tourisme qui est de la seule porte
d'entrée aujourd'hui pour les
territoires de montagne vraiment avec
une dépendance très forte qui vient du
coup forcément mettre en difficulté
énormément de gens et je pense que là
nous en tant que ville nous avons cette
chance de pouvoir vivre toute l'année et
de faire d'avoir des liens très forts
avec les territoires de montagne que ce
soit avec le grand Bordeaux par exemple
sur le la Coupe du Monde de biathlon que
n'accueille ensuite l'été en version ce
qui roue pour montrer qu'il est aussi
possible de voir la montagne
différemment que avec dans le prisme de
la neige et dans le prisme du tourisme
de masse et c'est là où je pense que ça
devient intéressant voilà donc prenons
ce temps de planifier et pendant prenons
ce temps de vraiment réfléchir ensemble
est-ce que l'on veut je vous laisse
répondre
et qu'on y réfléchisse et que vous aurez
des propositions de la part de
saisonnier parce que là et en général
des salariés qui participent à la vie de
la saison mais effectivement mais cette
réflexion on pourra l'avoir tant qu'on
voudra on remplacera quand même jamais
le ski
j'arrive à compenser oui on arrivera
peut-être à compenser mais on remplacera
pas et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
cette vision de l'avenir et si on perd
cette vision de l'avenir
on perdra l'essence même de ce qui fait
notre valeur c'est 8% du pays le
tourisme c'est important Renault c'est
4%
je vous laisse le mode conclusion du
coup c'est écoutez déjà de dire et
peut-être de clarifier que même au
niveau des domaines ce qu'il y a de
France on a eu un congrès et on est
clairement aligné sur la revendications
qui sont celles-ci sur la pénibilité sur
les différents accès je suis entièrement
regrette aussi non mais pénibilité etc
parce que
évidemment sinon ça serait pas venu mais
on a aussi solliciter les ministres
directement donc c'était à Lyon je sais
pas si vous étiez mais on a parlé on a
parlé d'une même voix et puis après pour
la planification de la neige aujourd'hui
il faut regarder vraiment les éléments
qui sont scientifiques on a juste dit un
outil qui s'appelle Klim snow qui est en
lien avec Météo France avec des
chercheurs on sait maintenant à 2050 si
on respecte les accords climatiques
qu'elles seront les secteurs qui seront
viables plaviables et c'est à partir de
ces données scientifiques et climatiques
que l'on pourra travailler sur un plan
neige et déjà les régions l'État a déjà
fait des plans à des plans neige et il
faut faire vite
il faut faire vite
[Musique]